hi everyone it's Jerry I have a
beautiful game to share with you that
was played in 1994 between Gary kasprov
on the white end and Vladimir kramnik
the final tactical sequence in this game
by Kasparov is really something special
the graph I share at the end is going to
have an issue
at one point it thinks that it's an even
position when in reality white is
completely winning
the engine in short is experiencing a
horizon effect or a horizon problem
there is some depth to this combination
as you will see
all right
we open with a sicilian and eventually
we will hit out an open sicilian's
veshnikov
how do we get there by an uncommon move
order Knight G to E2 instead of the far
more frequent Knight F3
the main thing I see with this is that
the f-pawn is free to advance this move
this variation has a name it's noted as
the chameleon variation
why is that the term used I believe it's
because white could still change course
depending on what black plays here
could maybe take it into closed Sicilian
territory for instance if black on move
3 goes with D6 maybe this is where white
could think a bit more about the closed
Sicilian with G3 Bishop G2
the f-pawn is ready to go in these lines
in this game though black continues with
Knight F6 prepping D5 which would be an
excellent reply to G3 white says fine
I'm going to hit it and hit in the
center first in comes D4 and by
transposition here we are whether the
Knight is capturing on D4 from E2 F3
same story
same position
E5 now hits
zveshnikov's Sicilian
the Knight has to do something two holes
are created in Black's camp with this
advance and if you want to be a friend
to your opponent go ahead and take this
Knight and in that way you've helped
repair D5
no friends in this game Knight D to B5
eyeing up D6 that's cut out Bishop G5
pinning the Knight what do you do when
you're in a pin
challenge the pinning piece break the
pin both would be terrible moves black
is in an only move situation here has to
play
A6 has to address this guy
if you play H6 or Bishop E7 capturing
the Knight is a perfect continuation
and white is ready to pounce in the
center on D5 and maybe even land a fork
shortly thereafter
so
Knight has to be kicked
in the game Knight A3 is played
if Bishop takes Knight black must
recapture with the pawn taking with the
queen gets hit with Knight D5 Tempo
against the queen and then Knight C7
in this game Knight A3 we follow this
main line
this move cuts out Knight C4 and even
threatens to Fork the knights Knight D5
Bishop E7 only now do we have
black breaking the pin with Bishop E7
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop
that was White's good Bishop that was
exchanged for the night
and you should have a good reason to
exchange your good Bishop for a knight
what is White's good reason I get to
maintain this Knight in the center on an
outpost Square
all right from here C3
white could go with C3 or C4
in both cases C2 is now vacant for this
Knight to get back in the ball game
C4 is more aggressive
there's a thread on B5 but at the same
time it's more weakening D4 would be a
whole
so white says let me open up this Square
for the Knight and restrict your knight
all right from here castles Knight C2
Rook B8
this isn't considered best what's
considered best is Bishop G5
why is black playing Rook to B8 it's
anticipating this thematic Pawn break A4
black is saying if you play A4 here I
can take and if you take back I take the
B Pawn
okay
in this game after Rook to B8 we have H4
so this is no longer available
to Black
now what if the bishop did play to G5
here instead of Rook to B8
and then white went with A4
how can black reply to this by capturing
and after the recapture there's still a
you know white excuse me black has a
pick from here A5 is one option another
one
it's suggesting to throw the king in the
corner
get off of this diagonal and get ready
to break in the center with that five so
there's still many ways to play it from
here
in this game after Rook to B8
we have H4 there is no Bishop G5 and
there certainly is no Bishop takes Pawn
because black would be losing after
Queen H5
can't move the bishop you're gonna get
hit with mate
if you're defending like that cannot be
maintained
white is winning this is a poison pawn
and this Advance is clogging things up
for black
now challenges this night he goes to E7
I should note also
a reason to
want to put this bishop in this position
right here a reason to put this bishop
on G5 instead of Rook to B8 very often
this Knight will like to Pivot on E3 to
reinforce the strong Knight on D5 and in
many cases black is prepared to give up
his bad Bishop for the night just to
eliminate a a possible piece that could
be a great pest to Black on the D5
Square
alright in this game though it is Rook
B8 black is not given a second chance to
get on this diagonal
97 black knows what he's signing up for
with this he knows that the king side
could be broken up that's what happens
in this game Knight takes Bishop
what is black expecting to get in return
a Central Pawn break
black has a slight lead in development
after Bishop to B7 two things are
happening E4 is under Fire and D5 is
prepped
D5 basically cannot be stopped
Bishop D3 defends E4 in comes D5
Pawn takes Queen takes Rooks are
connected
for black queen hitting the pawn here
Queen side castles
this is now poison for sure that'd be a
pin and win of the queen but after Queen
side castles this one is up for grabs
black could take it but says you know
what I don't like the fact that this
bishop is staring right at a square
right next to my king go away
E4 first and only after the bishop falls
back do we have black grab the a pawn
now entering an end game for black
terrible idea
going for this why is this bad
well I think nearly everything
tips in White's favor in this ending the
first thing is the superior structure
for white completely healthy
uh control over this file
a great Outpost for the night a king
that is much closer to the center
playing this active role in the end game
now better Bishop
okay
I think that's a long enough list to
keep one away from
exchanging Queens bringing this to an
end game position in this game Queen
takes a
it's a pawn grab
still an evenish position there's no
follow-up threatening move by black this
Knight is quite the piece from C2
watches out for
watches out against Queen A4 check stops
Pawn break B4 this is a great Square for
a knight on E3 or even D4
it's ready to spring into action in just
a blink
all right from here Queen H6
strong post for the queen
hitting F6
Queen comes back
towards the center defending F6
Knight D4
Queen B6 not many options there
she has to still stay trained on F6
still around an evenish position Rook H3
do you see the idea
Rook H3 Rook lift
you can't really stop Rook G3 next so
the king
basically needs to hide get out of the
get off of the G file so that these
Rooks could get there
all right from here
this is where I took something away from
this game right around this point here
because you would think you know if you
said a
in other words if you set a rook H3
you say B you put this Rook on the G
file but the Rook doesn't go to the G
file in this position
if the Rook goes to G three right now
it's easily offset
the root goes to G8 and basically we're
just helping out this Rook
that was on the B8 Square doing nothing
in black is all of a sudden one
generating a threat
what does white come up with well
he goes with Bishop to G4 what is the
idea
behind Bishop to G4
he's trying to improve his Queen
as odd as that may sound
white is focused on an intersection
Square in Black's camp
whitest coordinating with this bishop G4
move white is coordinating with the
Knight on D4 these are two interesting
squares all of a sudden
what is a better Square for the White
Queen instead of H6 where would she like
to be
F6
after Rook G8 we have on board
night
E6 this is cutting off the queen from
defending F6
this is considered
a mistake by Kasparov and I'm really
glad he made this mistake because we
wouldn't have gotten to see
this beautiful sequence that is about to
happen
um
first of all what is considered best in
the computer's eyes is to play Bishop F5
pinpointing H7 Knight takes Knight takes
Queen E6 considers it an even position
in this game though 96 now what goes
into this move what sort of calculation
is necessary before you could pull this
move off what do you need to know
well you need to know what to do in case
of Pawn takes Knight you need to know
what to do in case of Rook takes Bishop
let's have a look at both now in the
game black replies in the best way
he goes with Rook G6 but what's
happening in the case of
Pawn takes Knight
well white would continue with Queen
takes F6 check black must play Rook G7
that's the only move
black has to go into this pin and then
Rook D7 and black is all pinned up rook
is pinned Knight is pinned and how do
you get out of this situation you can't
how do you defend the Knight Queen C5
and Rook 2
E8 they defend the night
but
they could both be met with Rook G3 and
next up there's Bishop takes pawn and
this is collapsing
so
there's no for instance let me just put
it on Queen here Rook here what are you
doing about Bishop takes pawn and then
Queen takes Rook
the Bishop from E6 would also be
attacking a rook if this guy slides over
to try and defend G7
so there's no good continuation here
for black if you take the Knight after
chop Rook D7
what about
Rook takes Bishop pop quiz
there's only one winning move here for
white
Can you spot it
feel free to pause the video
okay
there's a pin
in the position where we're really close
to having a pin a direct pin in the
position
what is that pin exactly where is there
an unprotected piece these are red flags
for you here's the PIN
Knight G5
this queen is unprotected
this guy is pinned there is no Pawn
takes Knight
and what are you doing about Queen takes
Pawn
Rook takes Knight
you would take here what are you doing
about Queen takes Pawn
this is completely winning for white
very attentive to this
pin along the sixth rank which was there
ever since move 21 ever since the night
went to D4
and as soon as the queen went to B6
there was a pin present
okay it's been lingering there for a bit
easy to miss
all right so we have a good response
in these two cases Pawn takes Knight
Rook takes Bishop in this game best move
played Rook G6 white gets out of
danger also hits The Rook this is where
black goes wrong
the best move here is to play Bishop D5
try and get rid of this Knight and it
says best is to withdraw the Knight
this move puts pressure on the Knight
also defends The Rook
okay what is Black's move in this game
Rook to E8
okay
white is now winning
Rook to D6 the computer doesn't yet
appreciate with the graph when I when I
share this Rook D6 still considers this
even it's not even
white is winning
the move played in the game Knight to D5
what else is there the queen is attacked
if she moves away white has a very good
continuation let's see the move in the
game Knight D5 only one winning
continuation for white
Can you spot it
feel free to pause the video and give
this one a think or two
okay
the winning move is
H5 so this is the start of this
beautiful combination by kasprov
uh well I would I would go step back it
really kicks off with Rook to D6 he has
to know that after Rook D6 Knight D5 he
has this in his back pocket
H5
so first of all
if you don't go with H5 let's say if you
take the queen this is considered an
evenish
end game right around here
okay
in this game H5 white is winning why is
this well let's see Knight takes Queen
and pawn takes Rook two things are
happening you ready what are the two
main things one
the black queen is attacked and two
white is threatening two
Queen
so this is a threat Rook takes Pawn this
plays out in the game
Queen takes Rook Rook takes an H2 check
King G8 only move Pawn takes Pawn check
Fork King takes rook and now at the end
of all this The Rook is captured back
the materials restored and the queen is
back on the scene
and in the end look at these aggressive
minor pieces compared to these two white
is
far better coordinated than black here
this is completely winning
let me go back and simply show that
combination again because it's that good
H5 Knight takes Queen Pawn takes Rock
Queen takes truck check check promotion
Queen back on the scene We Go From Here
Knight takes Knight Bishop check
only one move otherwise you're gonna get
mated King H6
Queen G6 is mate
no taking the Knight just yet white
wants to take the F6 Pawn with check and
is guaranteed to get that after the
queen goes here
doesn't matter where you go next Queen
takes F6 is hitting with check king f8
queen takes F6
King E8 Bishop takes Knight after the
smoke has cleared it is now white who is
up a pawn and this is completely winning
even if we get into a queen exchange
Bishop end game alone position in other
words white is completely winning
this ends suddenly in this one though
after Queen f8 one final move and that
is this deflection tactic Bishop D7
black resigns there's only one move King
takes bishop and then you would lose
your queen
so what do you think of this one
this is really a beautiful beautiful
combination again one that the computer
did not appreciate Rook D6 it was still
thinking it was even it was not even
white was already winning at that point
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye